hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video
ich kann jetzt richtig auf den tisch
hauen weil das mikrofon steht hier nicht
mehr
ich versuche jetzt mal mit so einem
kleinen micro hier ist glaube ich noch
keine ahnung ich weiß nicht warum ich da
nicht vorher drauf gekommen bin aber gut
ein halbes hendl im hintergrund ist auch
was neue ihr seht schon da ist jetzt so
einfach also dass frau wird auf jeden
fall auch noch ein bisschen größer
das geht noch weiter nach oben es sieht
jetzt hat queen aus ich habe hier auch
bei dem open schild dieses kabel weg
gemacht in so einem kabelkanal ja das
haben ja so viele geschrieben dass ich
das machen soll auf der anderen seite
sind die neon science ganz weg ich weiß
nicht ob ich wieder hin machen sollte
keine ahnung eigentlich bin ich nicht so
ganz zufrieden muss ja ehrlich sagen
aber ich habe mir auf dem neuen pc und
so geholt und das ist vor allem auch für
die live streams die ich machen möchte
der hintergrund dann halt link dazu ist
in der video beschreibung wir machen
heute etwas sehr nice es jetzt muss ich
auch hier oben in der ecke werbung
einwänden weil die box die wir auspacken
habe ich umsonst von naomi zur verfügung
gestellt bekommen viele von euch kennen
die firma wahrscheinlich auch unter cia
uni weil es mit ex geschrieben wird aber
es wird sciaroni ausgesprochen eine
absolut geisteskranke technik makel die
wachen so viel zeug ein allererster
saugroboter war auch von denen die
machen wirklich alles mögliche was man
sich nur vorstellen kann handys
kopfhörer bildschirme smardtv und das
alles finde ich zu einem sehr guten
preis leistungsverhältnis ich habe hier
die box bekommen passend zu den black
rider ich zeige euch die macht so sieht
das ganze aus ist gar nicht sonderlich
schwer aber mir wurde gesagt hier ist
auf jeden fall eine menge cooles zeug
drin und ich bin super gespannt das
ganze wird natürlich auch zu den sachen
ihr könnt nicht sehen aber da ist nach
riesenhaufen zur dezember verlosen
gepackt also es wird immer mehr und
immer mehr als kaum noch soviel
hinzukommen da könnt ihr euch auf jeden
fall drauf freuen und wir machen das
ganze jetzt noch vorsichtig auch nach so
dass es hier noch zugeklebt glaube ich
will es eigentlich gar nicht kaputt
machen weil die boxee zunächst ausruhen
einlädt
eins zwei drei vier jahren haben wir
drin und kugelschreiber kugelschreiber
kann man auf jeden fall immer gut
gebrauchen aber das ist ja langweilig im
vergleich zu dem es ist auch dein alter
ja ein geiles handy ich weiß welches
handy das ist ich hatte es noch nie und
ich freue mich umso mehr dass es da ist
finde ich es ist auf jeden fall ein
fettes handy und ich starte aber erstmal
mit dem sachen die wahrscheinlich nicht
so interessant
sind aber trotzdem noch zum beispiel
haben wir hier habe ich gerade gesehen
ein metier stick wenn ihr keinen smart
könnt ihr einfach diesen meetings in
euren fernseher stecken und habe dann
automatisch netflix youtube drei alles
möglich halt was man so braucht ich habe
allerdings ein smart tv deswegen kann
ich das nicht gebrauchen aber ich lege
es natürlich zu den ganzen sachen wir
können eigentlich auch mal kurz
auspacken weil ich muss sagen ich habe
diesen stick so noch nie gesehen also an
denen der den dann irgendwann mal kriegt
tut mir leid dass der schon auf ist
dafür dass die verpackung schon
eingerissen ist entschuldigung also
ziemlich simpel so wie man sich das
vorstellt einfach hier kann es in
verstecken mit hdmi-anschluss und let's
go glaube mehr muss ich dazu auf jeden
fall nicht sagen für die es interessiert
wenn ich hier auch die summe von den
produkten ein damit man halt so weiß wie
viel wert hier drin ist interessiert
mich selber auch deswegen macht es
einfach mal
wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
produkt und zwar haben wir hier aha da
bin ich ja der absolute profi niko weil
es ihr bad ways ich weiß garnicht alltag
in schwarz und ich habe gesehen wir
haben dazu auch noch andere in weiß das
sind allerdings sie mit wireless
earphones 2 basic bevor wir die als
auspacken und dann mal testen muss sich
noch darauf hinweisen dass ich zusammen
mit schaum diesem freitag von 12 bis 14
uhr einen live stream veranstalter und
zwar auf der offiziellen show me
deutschland website me.com und das ganze
zum glück nicht alleine sondern zusammen
mit john wo denn kennen wahrscheinlich
viele von euch hier könnt ihr euch hier
immer ein
wir werden uns auf jeden fall dahin
setzen das ganze findet statt im saturn
in köln und stream von daraus machen
geile challenger es gibt eine menge
coole verlosung es gibt rabattaktion usw
deswegen müsst mich mega freuen wenn ihr
alle am freitag in den livestream kommt
von 12 bis 14 uhr ganz oben in der video
beschreibung verlinkt ich euch das da
könnt ihr einfach auf den link klicken
wie gesagt eine verlosung es wird sich
lohnen und ich hoffe ich kann auf euch
zählen und jetzt schicken wir mal hier
die earphones empire watt was auch immer
noch so auch hier habe ich euch sicher
schon den preis eingeblendet ich habe
gerade gesehen die sind ziemlich
preiswert ließ hier kosten 22 99 zurück
bahn
auch hier sind tatsächlich nur die
kopfhörer drin also in meinem fall
absolut gar kein problem weil ich hab
eine milliarden von diesen kabeln
aber wenn man halt kein saatgut das hat
heutzutage anscheinend jeder deswegen
die werden sich schon was bei gedacht
bewegt auf jeden fall sehr hochwertig
danke schon mal dafür wir machen jetzt
hier dann noch die earphones auf ja hier
haben kabel bei ok das finde ich auch
sehr gut und die kopfhörer sind nochmal
einzelnen neben dann baller ich geh mal
hier in skate zack und so sieht das denn
aus finde ich auf jeden fall sehr cool
wir schauen gleich mal welche ich von
beiden besser finden welche den besseren
klang haben aber ich will jetzt erst mal
das handy hier raus und werde die
kopfhörer dann auch damit connecten
bietet sich an hier haben wir das mieten
leid auf jeden fall ein ziemlich geiles
smartphone ich habe schon vieles darüber
gehört hat natürlich auch seinen wert
ich glaube das kostet um die 500 euro
blende ich hier euch super gerne auch
ein
ich bin so gespannt weil das singen hat
wohl eine absolut kranke kamera wir
werden sehen und die gute nachricht für
euch ich gehe mal davon aus am freitag
am black friday im livestream wird davon
auch vielleicht das ein oder andere
rausgehauen designt weiter okay was
haben wir hier drinnen im case wird auch
mitgeliefert
ich bin nicht so der fan von cases weil
ich finde einfach das macht die
schönheit die eleganz von smartphones
einfach kaputt okay gut eigentlich ist
es sehr dumm weil sonst geht halt dein
smartphone kaputt und haben wir dann
auch schon das smartphone so etwas mal
rauf gebt euch das hier vier kameras die
haben ja nur das ladekabel drin
kopfhörer sind nicht dabei habe ich aber
jetzt auch genug ich würde sagen wir
machen es einfach mal an ich sehe gerade
hier schon man kann sogar zwei
sim-karten rein und dann kannst du
einmal das als arbeits handy neben
theoretisch und auch noch privat weil es
gibt ja sehr viele die meinen sie müssen
unbedingt zwei handys besitzen let's go
also ich finde das design wirklich ultra
gerade durch diese lila blau und farben
aus dem hintergrund wird das hier so
schön reflektiert ja ok daten immer ich
richte dass man eben ein
und dann packen wir das mal aus okay
leute handys hochgefahren so sieht das
aus ich konnte gerade wählen zwischen
zwei designs ich habe mich für limit
list entschieden
deswegen das ist so ein bisschen dunkler
da ist auch direkt schon drauf sehr wohl
keiner spaß es sind aber wirklich einige
apps schon drauf netflix ist auf youtube
ist drauf spiele sind schon drauf
eigentlich muss man sich das ja sonst
immer selber noch runterladen youtube
ist drauf youtube music ich muss
eigentlich direkt mal die kamera
auschecken weil die sicher so fett aus
die muss es auch geil sein einmal kurz
mit doug hayes so wie früher
man sieht halt voll meine augenringe
einfach weil die qualität so hoch ist
aber gut dann checke ich jetzt mal die
kopfhörer ab welche davon
besser sind ich bin gespannt vor allem
hier auch weil ich letztes jahr eine
menge kopfhörer getestet habe die alle
ungefähr bei diesem preis lagen also
hier aber schon mal die ehe von basic
die koppeln wir mal eben hier wird auch
direkt der akkustand angezeigt 70
prozent beim case 36 prozent bei den
kopfhörern sieht das teil ist gut aus
ich weiß es nicht werde ich gleich sehen
und jetzt hören wir hier mal rein
[Musik]
absolut gut für 30 euro ich meine die
kosten nicht mal 30 euro kann man sich
nicht beschweren sehr guter klang ich
bin jetzt mal gespannt auf die hier ich
gehe mal davon aus die hier sind besser
weil sie sind auch letztens erst raus
gekommen also auf jeden fall neuer als
die schwarzen hier aber an sich muss das
ja nichts heißen wir koppeln dann jetzt
mal die anderen hier gehen wir mal raus
die liegen halt auch ganz anders wahr
weil du diesen tropfen hier dran hast
aber gut dann bin ich auch damit
verbunden hören wir mal eben rein auch
auf jeden fall absolut akzeptabel wobei
die weißen hier schon besser sind die
kann ich euch auf jeden fall sehr
empfehlen ich muss sagen im großen
ganzen
ich bin großer fan von der marke weil
ich finde die machen halt absolut
preiswerte technik und deswegen freue
ich mich sehr auf den livestream am
freitag wollen auf jumbo und es wird
sehr sehr nahe kommt dann bitte
unbedingt in den stream alle sachen die
ich hier von jimmy zugeschickt bekommen
habt kommen dahinter handy werden im
dezember alle verlost deswegen lohnt es
sich um so mehr den kanal zu abonnieren
natürlich auch das handy ich hab da
hinten noch ganz viele andere handys
kommen noch weitere dazu und ja danke
fürs zuschauen leute und wir sehen uns
die woche wieder
es kommt nämlich endlich das video mit
den zehn laptops dich aus polen bestellt
habe also das war's haut rein